All data store queries are performed using indexes,
and knowing how they work is important when you
design and build your applications. If you have
worked with a relational database management system, and SQL.
You should be aware that those indexes are
not the same as data store indexes. Indexes in
RDBMS are a query optimization used to retrieve your
result faster. While indexes in Datastore are, in fact,
required to perform a query on that data at all. So you if you want to query for
Datastore data, there has to be an index for
that data. Be sure to remember this. So let's
look at Datastore indexes by going back to conferences.
And look at what happens when we perform a
search on the property city. In fact, let's even
talk about what happens before the query. When storing entities,
Datastore also updates index tables, which are
later used to find entities when the query
is made. These index tables consist of an
index value, that maps to a matching entity
key. Taking the city Berlin as an example,
the index value would be constructed using the
kind, conference. Then the property, city, and finally
the value of the property, Berlin. Here are
the index values for the cities Halloween,
London, and Paris. So again, the index value
is a combination of the kind, property, and
value of the property. Each index value then
points to the entity key where the value
resides. So a matching entity where city is
Berlin has the following key. And one with
London has the following key, and so on.
So let's say your favorite city is, Paris.
And you would like to get all conferences that
are in Paris. Then Datastore would look at the
index table where city is Paris, and find all
matching entities. Since data store require index tables
to perform queries, every property that you query for
will need an index table. By default, Datastore creates
these automatically. But we will also see how you
can control this later on.